please welcome Keanu Reeves
[Applause]
how's it going
all right good to see you thank you all
right all right I gotta talk to you
about something I mean I'm talking about
something
[Applause]
CD Projekt RED cyberpunk 2077 all right
a while back the guys from CD Projekt
RED approached me and asked me to be a
part of their new project cyberpunk 2077
they were going on and on about how
they'd create this vast open world with
a branching storyline how you'd be able
to customize your character through
in-game choices and it's not something I
knew before but I was excited by and I'm
always drawn to fascinating story
cyberpunk
is said in a metropolis of the future
where body modification has become an
obsession you play as an outlaw and
enhanced mercenary working in the sleazy
underbelly of this city yeah
okay let me tell you the feeling of of
being there of walking the streets of
the future is really going to be
breathtaking you're breathtaking you're
breathtaking
alright alright alright so I guess I
gotta finish this so tell me do you guys
want to know when there's one of the
release date yeah all right then check
this out
[Applause]
whoa way easy mr. Hanson am i right for
the job
okay
you have gone through to the other side
let's do this
you